all right I believe it integrating log
functions I'm talking about integrating
the kinds of functions that end up as
Long's okay so just to remember I want
to try and re-establish this this result
if I integrate whatever X okay okay so
to establish this into the rule result I
want to think back to did I'm not
started all right so where are we up the
log function is based in the exponential
function okay so let's just consider the
exponential function I'm not thinking
about all the bases I'm just thinking
about the one that that is basic okay
now this I can differentiate right I
know that dy on DX is equal to yes okay
but when I turn the tables switch things
around right if I have y equals log base
B of X so this is the inverse function
okay what can I do with it well I wonder
if you remember how we prove this result
last year what I'm gonna do is as so
many problems in maths are I'm going to
translate this into a problem I know how
to deal with mainly this one okay how do
I do that
so log function sorry this is a long
equation
I just want to rewrite it as an index
one right how would I do that
okay it's just the variables of small
actually that's how you get in this
function right so step four e to the y
equals x so I'm gonna write it the other
way around because what this makes clear
is you know exactly how to differentiate
this right just not with respect to X
because X is not the variable that you a
different table with respect to anymore
right
you would not do dy/dx u du/dx on do I
does that make sense because I've
switched variables the Y is the one that
is my input and
X is my output sir do you know what okay
now hold on a second I don't want the X
1 dy my original function was y equals a
little long okay so what's it everything
this and that well it's just a fraction
right so I can take the reciprocal so if
that's the X 1 dy then dy and DX will be
the reciprocal right except right here
we said we know exactly what even Y is
it's just X so here's my proof I'm
finished that's the derivative okay so
now by the same logic right I can say if
that's what differentiation does the
integration should take me in the
opposite direction if I integrate what I
ended up with again with respect to X I
should get back to my log function okay
and of course you guys know why you have
to add the cluster because this is an
indefinite integral okay now what is
this we want this stuff right how did we
get this result we got it basically by
mucking around with it algebraically so
it's algebraic that's okay but here's
the thing
use mental what about integration since
we prove this result okay you've learned
the integration isn't just that we
manipulating process right it actually
means something geometrically okay um
derivative means geometric turns well
what does it tell you that a graph so
it's a gradient right what does the
integral tell you cause we area right
but you see them agree that they were
reverse of each other now what does that
mean let's think about this one of rays
okay what does it look like draw it for
me okay it doesn't have to be
beautiful whoops sorry
I fixed it there's one of her ex okay so
when I integrate 1 over X over a certain
interval that should tell me area right
so for instance if I take an interval
like this pulled from A to B how do I
write this I would say the integral from
A to B of 1 over X with respect to X
that's what function is based on this
right it should be the log function and
I should evaluate it at a and B all
right you guys know what this is short
hair for it means it should be the value
at the upper limit and then subtracts
what you evaluate from the lower limit
we a kiss your farm sweet romantic but
something follows from this which is a
bit sort of less intuitive this area
right cuz it's an odd function ok should
make sense in your head that should be
the same but negative for this region
over here yes does this make sense
but for instance if I said the
boundaries we're not aiming by minus B
and minus a so perfectly symmetrical
okay
logic tells you that the integral from
minus B 2 minus a or 1 over X DX should
be equal to this but negative do you
agree with that because it's underneath
the axis ok so it should be negative log
B okay so that's but this isn't what you
get something goes wrong ok because when
you if I took my original law right I
would say instead of this I'll integrate
it from minus p.m. minus
a and you're like well this is just the
log function right so it's log X from
there's your boundaries okay and then
when you evaluate you evaluate the upper
boundary first and then you subtract a
little battery and you're like oh why we
just looked at this before right we know
this can't be there's no number no power
but you can raise e-soo to get a
negative number okay and this is
emphatically not that right though we
sort of know what to expect
and so we say oh but it's supposed to be
positive so we just saw that
conveniently say you know please don't
make it make it positive now in some
textbooks okay and I know I noticed some
new places they just do this that I well
it has to be positive okay so I'm just
going to just we're gonna make it
positive okay and they stopped absolute
value signs on okay so instead of seeing
this sometimes you see they're all
written like this okay here's the
whipping I kind of agree with them and I
want to show you why but the reason is
not cause we have to mention positive
because I don't know why say it means
that voice makes it seem less credible
but it does how does it work let's look
at this um the reason why this this here
is actually not a true statement okay is
because this integral it can't exist
over here because log X is just over
here okay that's why you end up with
this negative a negative B business
problem okay so what do we do we're
gonna have to redefine the integral for
1 over X as different over here as it is
over there so I'm gonna take this second
here whatever X if you integrate it for
positive values of X
this is what you get everything's fine
okay what what do you get on the other
side when you say the same function when
X is less than you well it's true I
actually do need to flip these values it
would work if the batter's was hit okay
because the order is correct right so in
fact it should be logoff minus X plus C
right when X is negative but when you
look at this carefully apart from a
being awkward for having two different
equations for two different branches
right you can see that something is
equal to X when it's positive
something is equal to minus X when it's
negative they see that exactly fits the
definition of the absolute value right
because absolute value of X is X when
it's positive and minus X when it's
negative so let's review this is why
this statement is correct okay it
actually is log of the absolute value of
x plus C but the reason why is not
because because you have to make stuff
positive because Long's it's an argument
from area that's why okay because you
have to define as something over there
cool it wasn't that make sense okay and
actually in real life and you've got
functions like this it's very unusual
for something you Reluctant behave like
both sides you just get one but
sometimes it's the negative side that
we're interested in right so you
actually have do you have to have a
proper definition for the negative side
okay